hello and welcome to this video playing
faulty Beck knows okay what do we get
no that's okay I'd love to go if I for
the three doors just very frequently
seen as well okay yeah go form the let's
say delayed Austrian attack yeah we're
there for was going d5 it's interesting
yeah well I have to go I have to go a
father's not a big choice there it's an
interesting way of playing actually so I
have to take it I guess and probably
should see 492 we're probably the set up
it's quite difficult for black to get
the g7 bishop in - yeah to make it count
in some way you cannot go f6 car of
course at the moment erm yeah just
because of the rules but threatening in
93 now trying to try to win the pawn how
we see it actually stopping me I don't
see how yes no f5 so if I take it
maybe there is c5 yeah and if I'd grab
there then g2 is hanging Messiah but
just cancel him Knight a six didn't
change anything in regards to the porn
no choice anyway I mean I'm not
particularly against grabbing this in
the first place and there was c4
threatened as well yeah I don't we need
for now also also all that easily but
maybe if I just take it and play rook to
d1 then c5 cannot be taken
this is not clear to me what this does
I'm sure
and maybe maybe c6 was concerning him
yeah maybe I don't know
so what to do I would really like to
make sure that I keep the pawn
c3 and before would be would be best for
that when this is a taking F form
yeah maybe this is um this is something
that helps anyway okay
yeah let's put this here that that sin
square bishop f8 I can just ignore if
you take sits he takes this assume this
is fantastic and now you will have to do
something about it
so just how good is that I mean it looks
nice but not sure if how big of an
advantage it is okay now he's got the d5
square it's definitely true hmm that's
true
hmm AAP defendant as well 55 looked like
a good move at least I couldn't really
figure out the drawback
oh that I didn't see at all not sure how
good it is but I didn't see it not not
not at all
Bishop is completely out of play
it's not too bad the night now and I've
got the the e-pawn maybe you can play
rook c7 trade everything down I Roxy 787
can also take on d5 but eight seven is
good do we need to second-guess myself
he cannot move anything here I can just
push everything forward
with too many pawns hmm
yeah I don't know it was a difficult
game really difficult game I mean I felt
like right right here I must be a lot
better here that is just not going to
work it's just way that's just a very
weak pawn but if we should be 793 okay
castles yeah it must be quite quite a
lot better right rook c8 yeah now I'm
not sure from him taking rook e1 is at
least one of the top engine choices we
should age six and here mr. e six oh yes
I have rope d7 oh that's very strong hmm
yeah normally you would think okay it's
six that doesn't do much because the F
pawn will move but I've got rook to the
seven and this is a this is killing
almost you cannot take it this is a nice
way to lose and this is a check this is
attacked pretty awful so that was a
strong move no I didn't look at it you
know I was always like I looked at it
briefly before and I was always thinking
okay no use he moves the F pawn and I
haven't gained much rather giving this
more square when it was on g7 but okay
so 92 is his name but it keeps a huge
advantage he's six and now group d6 I
should take and play Knight c3 Knight c3
it's not bad right attacking b5 mmm yeah
of course I mean I was already very
attracted to the exchange sacrifice this
is a kind of standard sacrifice but the
issue is that okay then the engine wants
me to sacrifice
94 93 that's interesting I mean this is
this is disastrous it just it's just
overwhelming with the super strong pawn
and I mean the pieces don't coordinate
here for black one idea from you know so
the problem is not the capture on the
six I presume its engine wants to do
this so that Knight takes e5 is now
possible so the engine wants to simply
ignore the whole thing and take on c5
okay I understand
and now it gives this line just
interesting hey rook c5 funny he
exchanged sacrifices here you know of
course if I now take this is very okay
for like a I mean actually not just okay
even better but I don't have to take I
can take a seven keep my or just stay
the exchange down yeah yeah yeah it's um
that this is interesting but okay here I
think I'm better but it was very
complicated really 93 I really did not
appreciate this move at all it was
possible the whole time okay Bishop a7
as well but this is just good yeah
covering d5 attacking b5
no it wasn't really on my radar that's
the move I liked during the game and
engine agrees so 94 isn't great I mean
okay we didn't have much time but you
form the ship takes then 95 mm now this
is still quite good right
was there something else I have a six
yeah I mean it looks very nice here with
this pawn on d6 but it is not so easy to
make anything tangible out of it this is
probably the issue
I don't like c3 doesn't help and t5 as
it would square him I'm still rather
white him but the engine gives them some
slight advantage you know I was G
forward it's not totally simple okay so
a six I played King f2 a3 was better
okay and now Knight eggs probably take
Jake and b3 should be excellent yeah
yeah I just just cuts cuts out the piece
and here it's completely winning
but there was roopd for him yeah this is
kid this is the toughest offense but I
thought I thought it should win you get
this year potentially and then you had
stuff to say to Sitwell can you show me
something
the black king just doesn't get down
doesn't get out and I'm always ready to
do this if the pawn starts to him it
starts through and starts ago I think it
should win which I think it does yeah
okay guys thanks for watching